der berühmte aachener dom erstrahlt im
licht
denn das wahrzeichen der stadt hat ein
besonderes jubiläum vor 40 jahren wurde
es als erstes bauwerk deutschlands von
der unesco zum weltkulturerbe erklärt
am eröffnungsabend ist es kalt und
regnerisch doch das verdirbt den
besuchern nicht die stimmung
ein jahr lang hat lichtdesigner
christoph fehlen an diesem projekt
gearbeitet haben also es ging darum
jetzt im rahmen dieser festwoche für 40
jahre weltkulturerbe vom dom
darzustellen wie der dom immer gefahren
ausgesetzt ist im laufe seiner 1200
jahre und je die aachener ihnen immer
wieder gerettet haben jetzt das ist
natürlich alles ein bisschen
künstlerisch dann interpretiert für die
3d lichteffekte sorgen 14 projektoren
und die sogenannte pixel mapping technik
dreidimensionales bild hat nur die
vorderseite die für sie
die ist eigentlich kennt vor mit einem
laserscanner das mögliche 3 d daten wir
wissen von jedem punkt in welcher
entfernung von hier zum beispiel der ist
und mit diesem wissen wo welcher punkt
ist können wir dann eben mit anderen
software an den inhalt bauen
der genaue plus gebäude angepasst über
jahrhunderte wuchs der aachener dom zu
seiner heutigen gestalt der älteste teil
ist die pfalzkapelle aus dem achten
jahrhundert
karl der große hatte die
mittelalterliche kapelle als teil seiner
kaiserpfalz errichten lassen
sie ist alles was von der residenz des
sogenannten vater europas übrig
geblieben ist und sie ist seine letzte
ruhestätte
[Musik]
es ist schon eine voraussetzung wenn man
einen solchen status welterbe hat dass
das bauwerk auch erhalten bleibt und
dass auch die stadt dafür sorgt dass es
beispielsweise schutzzonen rings um den
dom gibt dass es keine hochhäuser gibt
die denn in der sichtachse des aachener
doms liegen
aber da haben wir den eindruck dass da
die stadt auch sehr darauf achtet dass
der achter dom diesem status
weltkulturerbe erhält das besondere ist
natürlich dass hier im achter dom im
mittelalter über 30 könige denn auch
krönt worden sind wir haben oben im hoch
münster haben wir den karlsruhe der auch
von höchstwahrscheinlich von karl dem
großen errichtet worden ist
im september 1978 wurde aber nicht nur
der dom zum welterbe ernannt sondern
auch das ihn umgebende zentrum der
historischen stadt ein bis zwei
millionen euro kostet das jedes jahr die
kathedrale in stand zu halten
zurück auf dem katschhof vor dem dom
gleich soll die lichtshow beginnen
christof hille führt die letzten
technischen checks durch und dann geht
es los
die geschichte des doms zieht als
lichtspektakel an den zuschauern vorbei
[Musik]
dem publikum scheint es zu gefallen es
war genial es war genial weil man hat ja
den dom sieht man eigentlich so jeden
tag
und hier wird dann noch einmal richtig
präsent in allen facetten die auch die
geschichte des domes letztendlich
widerspiegelt ich kann die geschichte
vorher nicht natürlich die die einzelnen
bestandteile das kennt man schon
und es war einfach dass ich ja also ich
habe die einbauten mit feuer und sofort
waren schon beeindruckend ist ja also
mir sehr viel spaß gemacht auf jeden
fall dass ich mal anzugucken also hat
sich voll gelohnt wetter war egal hier
regnet immer machen das ist wirklich
sehr gut gelaufen aber das war sehr
fruchtbar wurden ganze ideenfindung und
die arbeit daran hab sehr viel spaß
gemacht
seit vielen jahrhunderten ist der
aachener dom ein beliebtes ziel von
millionen von pilgern und auch an diesem
festabend ist er ein echter
besuchermagnet
[Musik]